after producing a video about fake
quotes that circulate around that are
attributed to aristotle i ask people who
they would like to see me tackle next
and it was overwhelming in all the polls
that i did plato so as it turns out
there's a lot of fake plato quotes out
there sometimes attributed directly to
plato sometimes to socrates since
socrates is a major character in plato's
dialogues and there's lots and lots of
them circulating around so i just picked
10 of them that i thought were
particularly interesting or problematic
or egregious and we're gonna go through
each of these and i'll tell you
where it comes from when we do know that
and also why this isn't likely something
that plato would have said in most cases
so with no further ado let's look at our
very first one now this is not a
terrible thing to say but it's just not
by plato be kind for everyone you meet
is fighting a hard battle it's not just
attributed by the way to plato but also
to filo of alexandria but it's not from
either of them it is actually from this
scottish preacher ian mclaren back in
the close to the turn of the 19th to the
20th century and then it gets picked up
by a whole bunch of people for example
dan millman in no ordinary moments a
peaceful warrior's guide to daily life
and we see this happening from the 1990s
on where lots and lots of people
uncritically taking a quote like this
that they think perhaps came from plato
but they haven't actually read any plato
now why would plato probably not have
said this this be kind is not a common
locution in greek texts you know you
could say something maybe translate be
benevolent to people
do good to other people and this notion
everyone you meet is fighting a hard
battle that's pretty new-agey you know
even though it's going back quite a ways
so it's it's not something that plato
says anything like in his works
let's look at the next one now this is
also an interesting saying watch a man
at play for an hour and you can learn
more about him than in talking to him
for a year now this is something that
plato would never have said because
talking is in general the way that you
learn about people in the platonic
dialogues and you could say something
like well watch a person's actions and
you'll learn a lot about them but
watching them at play probably
not
this is actually
a paraphrase of a statement which is in
a work by richard lingard in a letter of
advice to a young gentleman leaving the
university concerning his behavior and
conversation in the world 1907 so you
know that's when people said wordy stuff
like that and it says here if you would
read a man's disposition see him game
then you will learn more of him in one
hour than in seven years conversation
and little wagers will try him as soon
as great stakes for then he is off his
guard again this shows up in later
literature it gets attributed to plato
in a 1987 book by alan loy mcginnis
plato in confidence how to succeed in
being yourself but he's taking it from
somebody else and attributing it to
plato and then from that point on
it's out there and people will think
that it is indeed plato
let's look at the next one now wise men
talk because they have something to say
fools because they would like to say
something or they have to say something
there's variations on it the quote
sometimes continues as empty vessels
make the loudest sound so they that have
the least twitter the greatest babblers
not in this particular one that we've
got imaged here and notice this is
really quite something here it's not
just attributing it to plato philosopher
but plato philosopher and historian
it's rather unusual to see plato called
a historian so there's kind of a double
mix up here now where is this actually
coming from there's two early 20th
century works in which we can
find this attributed to plato even
though it's not from plato's texts one
of these is the 1903 book by abraham
coleman proverbial wisdom proverbs
maxims and ethical sentences of interest
to all kinds of men and then there's
also the tyron edwards book in 1908 a
dictionary of thoughts being a
cyclopedia of laconic quotations from
the best authors of the world both
ancient and modern so they both managed
to get it mixed up perhaps edwards drew
from coleman we're not really quite sure
but there may have been a source text
earlier that we don't have
this next one is very interesting we can
easily forgive a child who is afraid of
the dark the real tragedy of life is
when men are afraid of the light
not by plato you're not going to find
this anywhere in his text we do find
something kind of like this in seneca
who is talking about lucretius
a epicurean author who's a little bit
before him saying we are as much afraid
in the light as children in the dark so
that could be a possible source of it
but we're not exactly sure where this
comes from there's a lot of reworking
going on if it's actually the working
off of the seneca piece it's definitely
not by plato though now here's an
interesting one that actually has some
variants floating around music is a
moral law it gives a soul to the
universe wings to the mind flight to the
imagination
charm to sadness gaity and life to
everything and you notice that this
particular instance of it doesn't have
exactly that formulation i think people
are monkeying around with it a bit
there's also a variation out there
books give a soul to the universe wings
to the mind flight to the imagination
and life to everything so we know that
that one is probably coming from this
earlier one claiming that music is the
moral law and this is not by plato this
is actually by a guy
john lobbick who
has a whole bunch of different uh
attributions principal of the london
working men's college president of the
london chamber of commerce et cetera et
cetera published in 1889 in his
pleasures of life part two and now you
could say well wait a second plato loved
music and you know he did have a
cosmological sort of view on things
couldn't this be by him um
yes and no he wouldn't have called it a
moral law plato thought that music could
be used for good or for bad if you want
to check that out look in you know the
republic where he discusses various
modes of music and their good and bad
effects on people and it's not music
itself that does all of these things
that are being attributed to it giving
soul to the universe wings to the mind
flight to the imagination no that's
that's going a little bit too far
although music is important
i think you can kind of tell right off
the bat that this is not going to be by
plato in part because you know they did
have terms that would correspond to
meaning like the meaning of a word or
the meaning of a term but this notion of
meaning of life is
a little bit
foreign there's lots of greek
terminology talking about like the
purpose of life or the point of life you
know telos there's you know what we
value in life what we consider important
the kind of lives that we choose but the
meaning of life is not something that
we're really going to see
in
ancient philosophy and particularly in
plato and as it turns out this comes
from two 20th century sources both of
which are talking about plato but
reformulating matters so aaron's casira
great philosopher writes in his 1944 an
essay on man what is man man is declared
to be that creature who's constantly in
search of himself a creature who in
every moment of his existence must
examine and scrutinize the conditions of
his existence he then quotes the
unexamined life is not worth living and
abraham joshua heschel in 1954
is quoting kasir and then introducing
some further considerations he says
nowhere in plato's socratic dialogues do
we find a direct solution to the problem
what is man there is only an indirect
answer now he's taking this from kasir
not directory from plato man is declared
to be that creature who's constantly in
search of himself a creature who in
every moment of his existence must
examine and scrutinize the conditions of
his existence and then here we get the
quote he is a being in search of meaning
so we have a rather existentialist plato
here which is to say not the plato that
we know from his actual texts
this is another common one that you see
floating around quite a bit atheism is a
disease of the soul before it becomes an
error of the understanding and this is
coming from what we could call a
mistaken attribution a summary that's
being given of what plato is supposed to
be saying but not actually coming from
plato's text and it's attributed to
plato's laws by this author william
fleming and then it gets quoted by
somebody else who's taking william
fleming at his word in prose quotations
from socrates to macaulay by samuel
austin alibone so fleming is claiming
that this is what plato says in the laws
and you can't really find anything
corresponding directly to this in it so
it seems to be fleming's misremembering
or misattribution that gets this going
and this becomes a real darling among
conservatives you can find it for
example in conservapedia and in other
places where it's being regurgitated
if you know your ancient philosophy well
then as soon as you see this you're most
likely going to say no that's not plato
that's actually
clearly aristotle although it's not
actually what aristotle
says and it's kind of a weird
translation as well and so we'll see why
in just a minute so excellence is not a
gift but a skill that takes practice we
do not act rightly because we are
excellent in fact we achieve excellence
by acting rightly now if you know you're
greek you would say okay excellence
virtue you know arete great that's fine
a skill
well
that sounds like techne and that's not
something that plato or aristotle
actually say takes practice okay that
kind of fits this we do not act rightly
because we are excellent we achieve
excellence by acting rightly that's a
little bit fishy as well it's hard to
pin down exactly where it's going to
come from it doesn't come from plato
this comes clearly from aristotle but
where is it coming from will durant
where so many other fake quotes end up
coming from will durant didn't ever find
a thought that he couldn't paraphrase
himself into a catchy thing that then
other people would say oh well that must
be what indeed schopenhauer or bergstone
or in this case plato or actually
aristotle said so this is not entirely
off but it's definitely not by plato and
it's not actually by aristotle either
everybody's heard this one necessity is
the mother of invention and it's not
completely off base it is the result of
benjamin jawet a great commentator and
translator but sometimes a little bit to
taking liberties in his translations so
you know he translates this passage from
plato's republic book two as the true
creator is necessity who is the mother
of our invention and this is a little
bit periphrastic meaning that things are
being introduced here that are not there
in the actual text jawed actually does
give a better translation at another
point saying our need will be the real
creator so no you know mother there and
no invention either so
you know this is an interesting quote
not by plato
but it's deriving from a matrix of
garbling things up and adding a few
things in
here's our last fake quote and this is
fake in a couple different ways it is
kind of connected to plato and if you
know enough about plato's anthropology
and about the terminology that he uses
and that translators have employed to
render some of the things that he's
saying this this can make sense but you
wouldn't catch plato saying human
behavior right human actions
choices
lives those things would make sense
human behavior is a weird weird
translation and saying that it flows
from three main sources you can
understand where this is coming from but
this is kind of a garbling up of things
desire emotion and knowledge now
why is this off emotion is actually a
terrible translation of thumos which is
often translated as anger the spirited
part of the soul another beautiful
translation the incandescent part of the
soul which you can find in the filo
kalia it's not emotion although that is
probably there because somebody
translates the passionate thematic part
of the soul or passion itself as emotion
wrongly desire so plato thought that we
have all sorts of desires
plural and you can talk about it in the
singular as well this is epithumia
desires for food for sex for all these
sorts of bodily pleasures right so that
that is indeed something that people are
driven by in the republic and then
knowledge episteme in greek no it's not
actually
what human behavior is flowing from more
reasoning or the rational part and you
can take all three of these together you
know as
the parts that plato is actually talking
about in his text but this is really
what should we say this is a hot mess of
a rendering i won't even call it a
translation it's sort of a bad summary
that somebody came up with of plato's
doctrine and i i think if we did enough
searching we could probably track down
the original of it and it's not totally
wrong right it does connect up with some
things that plato is saying but boy is
this misleading so that is definitely a
fake quote
what can you do in order to avoid
re-sharing fake quotes because nobody
out there i i hope is going to
deliberately create fake quotes but what
can you do as a responsible member of
whatever we're going to call the current
internet regime that we live under the
new republic of letters well the first
thing is anytime that somebody quotes
something and they don't give you the
source text you shouldn't in fact
exercise healthy suspicion especially if
you know something about the author and
this sounds like it doesn't quite fit
what you do know about the author be
suspicious if you know that something is
a fake quote or even if you suspect that
it's a fake quote don't repost it
because you're just adding to the
already too many fake quotes that are
out there drowning out the real things
that are being said by these people and
you're becoming part of the problem
rather than part of the solution when
somebody quotes something don't be
afraid to ask them where did that person
say that because if they actually know
they'll be happy to tell you and if they
don't know it's quite likely because
it's a fake quote and it's a good way to
find out when you should exercise this
suspicion
i'd also like to single out a website
that i think is particularly helpful
sentence i antique y which you can go to
and check out you'll find the link to it
in the video description below and that
wraps up this first installation of fake
quotes wrongly attributed to plato
you